The joe rogan experience,
you've,
um,
you've kicked the green bitch.
Yes,
yes.
After a 24 year intense relationship with the,
uh,
the green goddess or the Green Bitch,
depending on what mood she's in,
I had to stop.
Um,
and uh,
I've come in for some,
I've convinced for some,
for some criticism for their son and I feel it's important to say that,
uh,
I hugely value and a love cannabis.
I think it's a wonderful herbal ally and I think that,
I don't think that I would ever have written my books off historical mystery if
I had not encountered cannabis rather late in life.
I did not smoke,
uh,
Eddie Dope until I was 37 years old and I'm now 62 wire and roughly rad about
the age of 38.
That's when I started getting into historical mysteries for that.
It was all,
of course,
it's total stoner style.
Absolutely.
Before that it was all carried.
The fairs,
you know,
so,
but suddenly something opened up for me and I'm very,
and I'm very grateful to the herb for that.
And initially my eye,
again,
I need to emphasize this.
I think the problem I eventually ended up having with cannabis,
it's not the fault of cannabis,
it's the fault of Graham Hancock.
I think my relationship became abusive with the herb.
It was not initially.
Initially it was something I would do evenings and weekends.
I would not try to write while I was actually stoned.
I would do my days work and then chill out in the evening with a pipe or a
joint.
That was,
that was how it was for me for quite awhile.
And I went through my first big historical mystery book,
the sign and the seal,
uh,
which was published in 1992 with that pattern.
In other words,
that I would be,
I would be smoking only after I down tools at the end of the evening and I was
ready to chill.
Um,
and that worked fine.
But then when I started,
when I started writing fingerprints of the gods,
which was the biggest book I've,
I've ever done,
a 5 million copy bestseller all around the world,
when I started writing that,
I thought,
I'll experiment.
Let's see if I can be stoned and right.
And I discovered that I could,
I couldn't be stolen.
Right.
And I like being stuck so much that in a way it,
it urged me to just write all the time,
you know,
because then I had this,
I had this incredibly good reason to be stoned all the time and,
and um,
it took away all the physical boredom of sitting there in my chair in front of
my computer screen,
just everything went away and I went into,
drifted into this space where I could explore ideas and manifest those ideas
down,
down on the page.
And I literally,
that's when I began what was to become ultimately an abusive relationship with
cannabis,
which that I would fire up in those days,
might my joint or my pipe at a nine or 10 in the morning.
And I would,
I'm a hard worker.
I work 16 hours a day very often when I'm writing.
So come two o'clock the next morning,
I'd still be there smoking away.
Um,
and as the years went by,
this became a permanent daily pattern for me.
Whether I was writing or not,
I would be stoned from the moment I got up until the moment I went to bed.
And most people who came by my house or talk to me on the phone,
they would have had absolutely no idea because I was,
I was completely in control.
I didn't seem hi,
I could hold a rational conversation.
I was,
I was just fine.
Um,
and I've just felt,
I just felt really good.
Uh,
and this is how it went on for many years.
later on about in the early to that Renova 2005 actually I think perhaps a
little earlier,
one of my kids told me that,
you know,
this stuff,
this smoke is,
you don't need to have combustion products.
Why don't you use a vaporizer?
So I bought myself a volcano and on the Internet and,
and um,
and then I heard that the British government was going to ban the use of ban all
peripherals.
So I bought myself two more volcanoes.
Volcanoes are quite expensive,
but that shows how dedicated I was to make sure that you're covering your bases.
I had to make sure that I covered my bases.
Um,
and then I would be vaporizing from nine in the morning until two o'clock the
next morning,
seven days a weekend,
and increasingly strong strains.
And this is one thing that I would say if we lived in a regime and irrational
regime where there was no attempt by the government to police our states of
consciousness,
we could have much more choice in the kind of cannabis we get hold of.
For example,
I would have liked to have canvas with much more CBD and maybe less THC.
But the varieties I were smoking were very,
very THC,
THC,
uh,
loaded as the difference in effect.
Well,
okay.
I mean the,
it depends how much you buy into the research on this,
but,
but the law,
a lot of good science has been done.
And the suggestion is that THC can promote or reveal.
I don't want to,
I don't want to blame the herb.
Anything I,
it can reveal certain psychotic tendencies in oneself.
And this is the well known paranoia,
which,
which many people associate with,
with smoking cannabis.
The CBD is an antipsychotic agent.
So the natural herb is balanced with CBD and THC and,
and it looks after you very well,
but where we go into intensive breeding of the herb,
focusing on the element that makes you really high,
which is the Thc,
then we get,
uh,
get a herb that is somewhat unbalanced as a result of the interference of,
of,
of humanity and,
and,
but you get more bang for your buck.
You know,
that's a very,
that's a very strong herb.
And I began to like a particular variety called cheese,
I think it's called cheese because it smells like old socks or,
or,
um,
Stilton in like a blue cheese.
And a,
I found a grower who lived local to me who,
who was just heading amazing green fingers and,
and I would,
I would buy from him and um,
and I would sometimes have,
you know,
five or six ounces of the herb in my house cause I was blazing through this
stuff at the vendors at a tremendous rate.
That's enough to you where you could get in trouble for that.
So that's where the paranoia starts to become legitimate,
you know,
because actually they can numb,
they can break down your door and they can confiscate your home and take away
your liberty and fuck you up forever.
You know,
they can do that.
And,
and so every time I had a ring at the door or you know,
a car came up the street,
I would,
you know,
get,
get paranoid and get paranoid.
And you were high and I was high and I was high.
You get paranoid when you were a high,
well,
this is one of the reasons why,
look what happened to me was that run about 2003,
I started for reasons of research initially,
uh,
working with Iowasca,
the vine of souls.
This is the powerful psychedelic brew,
which has been consumed by shamanistic cultures in the Amazon for thousands and
thousands of years.
And it's not called the vine of souls for nothing.
It's a,
uh,
it,
it's a,
it's an extraordinary portal into other realms.
And,
and in some ways,
those realms are associated with death and perhaps of what waits for us after
death.
Nobody knows the answer to that.
But in I was,
you have certain experiences relating to that and right from the beginning when
I started to drink Iowasca,
I mean this sounds nuts to anybody who hasn't done DMT or who hasn't drunk
Iowasca but you do meet intelligent entities and more and more around the world,
people drinking Iowasca a meeting,
this goddess figure,
she might appear as a serpent,
she might appear as a woman,
she might appear as some kind of panther or Jaguar,
a very powerful,
tough love kind of lady who reveals to you the truth about yourself and just
says,
you know,
you fucking deal with it cause that's how you are.
And what the truth that was revealed to me from quite early on was my
relationship with cannabis and got out of balance and I needed to get it back
into balance.
And of course I ignored those messages completely because I was so,
I was so much in,
in love with my cannabis relationship,
but that my wife said that really it was like a head,
a mistress.
You know,
who I spent all my time with was the camp was the cannabis rather than rather
than her,
and this went on for many,
many years.
Now the paranoia aspect,
okay,
I'm going to bare my heart here.
And you know,
I believe in being honest,
the paranoia aspect began to affect my relationship with my beloved partner,
Santa,
who I just love from the bottom of my heart and she is the best,
the most,
the most pure hearted,
generous,
spirited,
loving lady.
It's possible,
possible to imagine,
but I started to develop all kinds of suspicions about her,
which were completely groundless.
I started to imagine all sorts of stuff we're going on and then I started to act
to act towards her as though those suspicions were real.
And all of this was also related to my consumption of cannabis.
It was not caused by my consumption of cannabis.
I think this is a latent aspect of my own personality.
It was being revealed by this over abuse of,
of the,
of the cannabis herp and,
and therefore I was making my beautiful partner's life a misery sometimes,
not every day,
but sometimes.
And she was patiently putting up with this,
but she was suffering and we went down to Brazil in October,
2011 and if I had been told when we got on that plane and went down to Brazil,
that when I came back two weeks later,
I would probably never smoked cannabis again.
I would have laughed in the face of the person who told me that.
But the encounters that I had with the spirit of Iowasca,
whatever that is,
I'm willing to accept that there is no spirit of Iowasca,
that it's all something we generate out of our brains.
But for me,
she manifests as a real,
like a goddess and the encounters I had with that,
and I do think she's real.
That's just my personal belief system.
And those encounters that I had were incredibly powerful and she took me to a
place that was something like hell and she took me to a place that was something
like the judgment scene in the ancient Egyptian religion.
Now the judgment scene is a place where your heart is weighed in the scales
against the feather of truth and harmony and cosmic justice and you do not want
your heart to be heavy in those skills.
You want to be able to look back on your life and say,
I did good.
I did not add to the misery in the world.
I did something worthwhile with this incredible gift of life that the university
gave me and I and,
and everything you've done every second,
every minute of your life is completely transparent.
Every thought,
every action,
everything you did from the moment that you became conscious until the moment of
your death is laid out before you and there's no hiding from it.
Like we great at creating illusions about our own behavior and persuading
ourselves that we're behaving just fine in the judgment hall of Osiris,
which is also called the hall of mark,
where the scene takes place.
All of that stripped away and you confront the truth.
And I was put there and I confronted the truth about myself and I saw the way
that I was behaving towards my partner and,
and,
and I was shown that this had to stop otherwise,
otherwise I was going to pay a huge price for it.
And it,
I had a series of terrifying,
terrifying experiences,
which my partner saw the science I've shared with me because we were drinking
IOWASCA together.
And at a certain point entities came to her and she had the experience of her
heart being pulled out of her chest.
And the entity said to her,
and she thought she was going to die.
we're going to do this to you to teach grammar lesson.
And Santa's communicated that to me.
And I would rank that as probably the single most terrifying night of my entire
life.
And I've had some terrifying nights that was just absolutely scared,
rigid.
And I,
and I came out of that with,
uh,
a feeling of very clear feeling in a,
in Iowasca we have sharings the next day after you've drunk the brew,
you share with the rest of the group who you've drunk with the experiences you
had the night before,
as much as you want to share.
And what I shared,
because I still didn't believe that I could stop smoking cannabis.
What I shared was that I was going to change my relationship with cannabis and,
and to get to a place where cannabis was serving me again rather than me serving
her.
Um,
and,
and that's what I believed.
But when I got back to England,
long flight,
what's the first thing I do?
I get out my vaporizer,
get out my stash,
fire up the vaporizer,
and fill a nice bag of
the vapor.
You said sort of stylistically,
well,
I miss it.
You know,
this was a,
that would be a cannabis is such a beautiful sensual ally if she's used right.
And what do you think?
It's just an imbalance issue with the CBD THC ratio and the,
let me,
let me just,
let me just finish with what,
with what happened to me.
So I fill up the bag and I'm down there in my basement and I take the first and
I take the first drawer and I'm suddenly filled with the most intense feelings
of horror and loading.
And it is exactly like I'm back in that space that Iowaska took me to,
and I try a second puff and I can't do it.
I physically could not continue.
I,
I knew that I just,
I just could not continue.
I expressed the vapor out of the bag,
I crumpled up the bag,
I put it away.
And the next day I got rid of several ounces of coke.
Cannabis.
Yeah,
I know,
I know.
It's terrible.
It's a terrible thing to do.
But,
but,
but for me it was the right thing to do.
24 years,
nonstop relationship with cannabis,
definitely abusing the herb.
I had got to the point where the only rational course of action was what I was
shown in Iowasca,
which was to stop.
And I don't know whether it was because there was way too much THC and not
enough CBD,
or whether it was just me not being responsible for my own behavior.
I go,
uh,
go around,
you know,
saying that I believe in adult responsibility,
and I do,
but I don't think I was being responsible.
I don't think I was using the herb in a responsible way.
I don't think I was using it in a respectful way,
and I paid a price for that.
[inaudible]
okay.
Freaks and geeks level.